welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and what does it mean to fall to the
dark side in Star Wars like what exactly
happened within Anakin Skywalker that
caused him to become the Jedi youngling
exterminator known as Darth Vader today
we're talking all about the single most
important factor that causes a good
person to fall to the dark side and that
factor is fear so let us take a journey
into fear together so we can better
understand Anakin's crazy transition
into the cyborg monster known as Darth
Vader but before we jump into that you
should jump into the spider-verse by
getting these new spider-verse inspired
shirts over at nerdriot.shop in case you
missed it new rock stars isn't just one
channel anymore it's three earlier this
year we launched the Deep dive where I
dig into the deeper meaning behind
everything you love and our newest
channel the break room is where all of
your nerdy friends are gonna hang out
online it's also the new home for inside
Marvel and all of our reactions to the
latest trailers TV shows and movies
we've got so many cool videos planned so
head on over and subscribe and while
you're at it don't forget to subscribe
to the new rockstars main Channel and
the Deep dive
too late to save you it is time you
realize that your guilt does not define
you my son you defined your guilt
the only love I feel in my heart
is haunted by what would happen should I
let go then it is not love it is a
prison
why Anakin Skywalker fell to the dark
side it is that moment from season 3
episode 15 of the Clone Wars animation
Anakin Skywalker's fear of being too
weak to protect those he loves his fear
of loss and his fear of weakness is what
ultimately leads Anakin to angrily
suffer on a futile Quest To Conquer
death to become the god of the Galaxy
basically because listen up y'all fear
is the dark side itself like if someone
were to ask you hey man what's the dark
side again you can just tell them it's
fear specifically letting your inner
fears and phobias cause you to lose your
identity and turn you into an angry
monster with the voice of James Earl
Jones everything that light touches
should be
rated
and Yoda famously gives Anakin the dark
road map that fear leads down in The
Phantom Menace fear leads to anger anger
needs to hate hate leads to offering in
Star Wars every single living being has
a dark side because every single living
being experiences fear in some form as
fear is an essential part of existence I
mean fear is a survival mechanism that
keeps us alive after all and the only
bad thing about fear is if you let your
fears consume you and make you do shitty
things to avoid becoming a hateful
selfish monster one must truly confront
their fears and let go of their
attachment to those fears something that
Anakin Skywalker was terrible at even
from a young age because like I said up
top Anakin has always had a crippling
fear of loss coupled with a fear of
being weak and we can see this even when
Anakin Skywalker was a good kid with a
good heart growing up on Tatooine in
slavery with his mother shimmy Skywalker
shmee is such a weird ass name sounding
like Captain books right hand man schmee
but since they grew up in slavery
Anakin's love for his mother was
abnormally strong because they were all
each other had I mean you know other
than water but let's be real here that
dude sucks and this being the case more
than most good Sons Anakin was deathly
afraid of losing his mother and also
feared not being strong enough to
fulfill the dreams that he's been having
of becoming a Jedi and freeing all the
slaves no one can kill a Jedi I wish
that was so I had a dream I was a Jedi I
came back here and freed all the slaves
and Anakin's fear of lost manifested
when he was super hesitant to leave with
Qui-Gon Jinn to start his Jedi training
specifically because he didn't like the
change of losing his mother as part of
his daily life carefully listen to this
interaction right here because what
Anakin's mother says is key it is time
for you to let go I don't want things to
change but you can't stop the change any
more than you can stop the sons from
setting life is all about change I mean
the sun comes up and goes down people
come and people go and eventually death
will take every living being in the end
spoiler alert sorry however throughout
his entire life Anakin could not accept
negative changes in his life and his
mother could sense Anakin's resistance
to Life's changes from the age of nine
like that moment right there is
extremely important to understanding
Anakin's descent into darkness because
this is where George Lucas established
Anakin Skywalker's main fearful change
his fear of losing the people he loves
the most because he was too weak to
protect him the very fear that would
ultimately lead him to slaughtering the
Jedi Order but speaking of the Jedi
Order when Qui-Gon Jinn brings Little
Annie to the Jedi Council they are
hesitant to bring this incredibly
powerful force-sensitive kid into their
group specifically because they could
all sense Anakin's fear of loss a fear
of loss that manifested in his
attachment to his mother afraid are you
no sir
see through you we can fear is the path
to the dark side
fear leads to anger anger leads to hate
hate leads to suffering
I sense much fear in you like Elegance
fear of losing Skywalker was so strong
that it filled the entire room and
believe it or not Anakin Skywalker being
a whopping nine years old was much too
old to become a Jedi because Jedi are
usually trained from ages much younger
than 9 years old to mind all the things
that they are attached to in life
because the more that you attach to
things or people the more you fear to
lose those things for people and the
Jedi smelled Anakin's fear all the way
from their thinking chairs and said this
kid is too damn dangerous to become a
Jedi at this point we are afraid that he
could become some type of Darth Vader
guy or something and let's be real they
were right they would ultimately let
Anakin join the Jedi Order to respect
Qui-Gon Jin's dying wish a lot of people
ask me how I'm able to stay focused
researching all these videos and
honestly it's this One-Shot energy
choose are a healthy and convenient
energy boosting supplement candy for
gamers athletes YouTube hosts and
everyone really
um
they make Energy Chews and Focus Shoes
the focus shoes are my go-to but it just
depends on what you need each energy
tube has 75 milligrams of pure caffeine
plus 600 milligrams of additional
nootropics to give you a serious energy
boost that works immediately as you chew
Focus chews really help me concentrate
and give me a natural boost of energy
with BCD and E vitamins plus zinc to
help with the immune system support and
the amino acid tyrosine both Energy
Chews and focus shoes are plant-based
naturally sweetened and designed to give
you the energy and focus that you need
without a bunch of fillers and chemicals
get started with one shot energy today
by going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off of your order
that's oneshotenergy.com new rockstars
for 10 off now fast forward 10 years to
attack the clones and Anakin's fear of
losing his mom has caused him to have
visions of her in pain causing his fear
of loss to grow I don't sleep well
anymore
because of your mother
I don't know why I keep dreaming about
her
dreams pass in time
I'd much rather dream about Padme
just being around her again is
intoxicating but Anakin has also
developed a new fear of loss over these
10 years rooted in his completely
unhealthy obsession with one Padme
Amidala like this dude has not seen this
girl in a decade and yet he tells her
that he's thought about her every day
since he was freaking nine years old all
those years ago
on a day has gone by when I even thought
of you
the thought of not being with you
I can't breathe okay imagine your ass
was a sophomore in college right and you
ran into someone that you haven't seen
since the fourth grade and then they
told you that they've loved you every
day since the fourth grade you would
call the police
like Anakin attached to Padme so much at
nine years old that he feared what life
would look like if he did not possess
her possess her being the keywords here
these are extremely abnormal levels of
attachment and that manifests in Anakin
being a straight up creep to Padme all
throughout attack of the Clones as he
relentlessly tries to acquire her but
let's check in on how Anakin's other
fear his fear of being weak progresses
in episode 2 because over the course of
his decade of being trained under
Obi-Wan Anakin's connection to the force
grew to unparalleled Heights but this
led to Anakin getting extremely cocky
and arrogant in his ability something
that worries Obi-Wan and the council
greatly but he still has much to learn
master
his abilities have made him well
arrogant yes
too sure of themselves they are and much
like with Anakin's fear of loss Anakin's
fear of weakness was Ultra dramatic and
extra as well because he feared Obi-Wan
and the Jedi Order were holding him back
from achieving his full potential as a
force wielder and that made him super
angry at the mall especially when the
council wouldn't recognize his abilities
or allow him to use his Jedi power to
help his mother much like he dreamed of
doing as a kid I'm ready for the trials
but he feels that I'm too unpredictable
he won't let me move on
he's overly critical
he never listens he he doesn't
understand it's not fair and of course
all of these deep fears become realized
when Anakin watches his mother die in
his arms like despite all of his new
power Anakin Skywalker could not stop
death and that fear turning into anger
caused Anakin Skywalker to turn to the
dark side for the very first time when
he slaughtered all of those sand people
I should call them Tuscan Raiders
because 10 people is probably very
racist
sorry Tuscan Raiders
we'll get this right this is when
Anakin's fear of weakness and arrogance
come out in full force when he expresses
his fear anger and suffering to Padme
why couldn't I save her
you're not all-powerful well I should be
I will be the most powerful Jedi ever
I will even learn to stop people from
dying it's all Obi-Wan's fault
he's jealous he's holding me back
like did you hear what this dude said he
said that he could have had Godlike
Powers over immortality if Obi-Wan and
the Jedi didn't keep holding him back
like Anakin losing his mom causes his
fears of loss and being weak to kick
into Mega OverDrive amplifying his
outrageous expectations of his own
abilities and his own future he
literally believes he can control death
that is wild and then of course in comes
Papa Palpatine the menacing Phantom
father of fear himself starts to
manipulate Anakin's fear of weakness in
episode 2 by gassing Anakin Skywalker up
and telling him that he's going to be
the strongest Jedi that ever lived and
that he's smarter than all the Jedi
Council basically stroking the ego of an
arrogant Anakin into making him fear not
being weak even more you don't need
guidance anything in time you will learn
to trust your feelings then you will be
Invincible you are the most gifted Jedi
I have ever met I see you becoming the
greatest of all Jedi and even more
powerful than Master Yoda he continues
stroking Anakin's ego in Revenge of the
Sith when The Phantom Menace makes the
outstanding move of using his political
power to force Anakin Skywalker onto the
Jedi Council when the Jedi didn't think
he was ready yet I'm appointing you to
be my personal representative on the
Jedi console me
a master like Palpatine knew the Jedi
Council was not going to like him
forcing Anakin onto the council because
he knew Anakin wanted to be acknowledged
as a Jedi master however Anakin's
training was not complete because they
all sensed Anakin's fear inside of him
so the council did exactly what
Palpatine wanted to not give Anakin the
promotion that his arrogance was craving
we did not Grant you the rank of Master
what
how can you do this
this is outrageous
it's unfair how can you be on the
council and not be a master
take a seat young Skywalker like
Palpatine played everybody in this
scenario he made sure Anakin's fear of
weakness turned into anger at the
council while also causing the Jedi
Council to grow fearful and suspicious
of Palpatine's motives the fear Master
General knew that the Jedi would
fearfully try to reverse Uno the
situation by asking Anakin to do a
dishonest thing and spy on Palpatine a
hypocritical act against the Jedi code
and the Republic itself it was basically
treason I have to admit
my trust in them has been shaken
they asked you to do something that made
you feel dishonest didn't I
asked you to spy on me didn't they
Palpatine knew the Jedi's Act of fear
against Palpatine would be enough to
convince Anakin that the Jedi were
plotting evil against the entire
Republic specifically because Palpatine
knew Anakin's fear of weakness and loss
were growing within him because of the
dreams that he'd been having of losing
Padme in childbirth which is why
Palpatine then immediately entices a
doubting Anakin was the one thing Anakin
has always wanted the unnatural power to
selfishly keep everyone he loves from
dying you never hear the tragedy of
Darth Plagueis the whites he had such a
knowledge of the dark side he could even
keep the ones he cared about
from dying
is it possible to learn this power
not from a Jedi the power of a god with
Palpatine now being the only path to
actually getting the power to never lose
anyone again and the Jedi who let him
down are now acting like political
enemies you can now understand why
Anakin barely hesitated to chop Mace
Windu's arm off it's not the Jedi way
[Music]
to Anakin Mace Windu was always getting
in the way of his fearful path to
acquiring the power of God to protect
the people that he loved in Anakin's
eyes he absolutely could not let Mace
Windu sentence Padme to die of natural
causes and this is when Anakin fully
embraced the dark side when he struck
Mace Windu in fear and anger and pledged
his life to the teachings of the dark
side itself just helped me save padme's
life
can't live without her
you shall be known as Darth
Vader
you've got yourself another Lord of fear
called Darth Vader Jedi exterminator
extraordinaire a newly minted monster so
fearful of losing Padme that his dreams
of her delivering their baby with
Obi-Wan and not him led him to accuse
Padme of infidelity than choking her and
then fighting his best friend for trying
to take her away the zoo was so paranoid
man Anakin Skywalker turned to the dark
side because he was insane amount of
possessive he could not accept that life
could just take things away from him and
that people could just do things that he
didn't want how dare they his fear of
not being in control of everything led
him to losing his identity and
everything that he sought to protect it
is only when Darth Vader as selflessly
lets go of his own life to protect his
son Luke that Darth Vader becomes Anakin
Skywalker again and redeems himself
because he faced his fear and he didn't
let that fear rule him at the very end
and that is exactly why Anakin appears
as a force ghost in Return of the Jedi
like I freaking love Star Wars man like
this whole series is all about teaching
us that no matter how much of a monster
your fear makes you become there is
always hope in Redemption and I think
that is so special and I thank George
Lucas for making such an amazing series
don't be like Anakin y'all your partner
is not your property they're only here
for a temporary amount of time to enrich
your life so just enjoy them while
they're here rather than trying to
possess them let's be healthy men for
God's sake but anyways that is Anakin's
Journey to the dark side let us know
what you guys think in the comment
section down below thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at misertainment on Twitter if
you guys want to see me tweet some weird
I love you guys so much and I'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
thank you